zum Glück können wir sie in Häuser wie
dieses hier sperren es ist wie ein
großer Bushaltestelle nur dass man hier
nicht auf den Bus wartet sondern auf ein
ganz helles Licht oder so ich weiß nicht
ich fahre nicht Bus aber auch hier in
diesem Haus muss ich ja leider jemand um
sie kümmern und damit sind wir auch
schon beim Kasus Knackpunkt es fehlen
jetzt schon
200.000 Pflegekräfte krass das ist eine
so so große Zahl aber sie stimmt und da
kommst du Deutsch Spiel
schau in diese Augen und sagt ja ich
werde den Pflegekraft
entschuldigung ich möchte nicht
respektieren aber das stimmt nicht mit
den Haare gibst du dir kein Conditioner
oh du meine Güte die Pflegeversicherung
sie zahlt kein Conditioner und das sind
so im rechten Land wie Deutschland
Skandal
[Musik]